hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be answering
all of your questions
around property investing property
entrepreneurship so
please do me a favor and comment below
in the question box with your property
questions
it can be anything at all from property
tax
mortgages securing a deal lease option
agreements hmos renter ants
anything at all and i'll do my absolute
best using my 12 years of experience
to answer your questions so get
commenting below with your questions
also don't forget to smash the like
button and also subscribe and turn on
the notification bell so you do not miss
a video
so let's see what we've got from last
week lots and lots of great questions
coming in how the guy could well
will richardson he says rent to rent
serviced accommodation
what tends to work better one or two bed
great question um so with service
accommodation just let me explain the
question in case anyone's thinking r to
sa what are you talking about
what it means is if you're going to do
rent to rent ie
rent a property off of a landlord with a
management agreement
and then list that property with consent
with proper contracts and agreements
list that property on
airbnb i mean geez you can rent a studio
flat for like what
five six hundred pound a month in many
parts of of england
but then you can rent them out on airbnb
for like 80 pounds
a night which means after a week
the landlord's paid for and then you've
got three weeks
of course you can have some costs or you
can just rent the property every day
so the question is are you better off
going for one bedrooms or two bedrooms
and the answer is it really depends on
the area of what what your
demographic is so if if it's a one
bedroom
you're just gonna rent the entire thing
out to one person
if it's a two bedroom you need to think
am i gonna rent this out
room by room as serviced accommodation
or am i just going to rent out the whole
thing
if you're going to rent out the whole
thing or room by room what that depends
on is that depends on the demand in the
area
so if people are desperately looking to
just crash
and then be happy in that area to stay
in a room in an apartment then maybe
rent it out by the room
i probably wouldn't with just a two-bed
apartment also what's the difference in
price
to the landlord if for a one bed it's
500 but for a two bed it's
800 it's quite a big difference in price
so
there's many different factors but with
service accommodation as well you're
going to look at the floor plans you can
think
how can i best configure this to get the
maximum amount of profit
systemized as heck and
according to the demand in the area
um the supply etc um
one of the things that we do is we rent
out we'll we'll
even if we've got a large property like
a three bed house
we might not rent it out room by room we
might say
we're gonna rent out the whole thing but
we're gonna make it um we're gonna we're
gonna
make it so that we can um change the
rooms around
so for example zip beds so if you've got
a one bed a two bed you could have one
of the bedrooms
could have a double and the other
bedroom could have a double
but with a zip in the middle so you can
turn it into a twin room so that you'll
be able to cater to as many people as
possible
and really maximize the price so i'd
recommend getting good at this because
right now staycations are really really
a thing
and people i'm a lot of people making a
lot of money from rent to service
accommodation
in the uk and across the globe okay um
razvan gabriel what percentage of your
money do you usually pull out from a brr
deal and how long does it take
all of it i want to pull out all of it
that's the formula if i'm buying a house
for
75 grand and i'm spending 25 grand
on it that means i'm putting in in total
100 grand
i'm probably not gonna pay stamp duty
because probably the house was
completely
inhabitable when i bought it which means
you don't pay stamp duty tax
um so if i'm putting down 100 grams
i'm gonna work backwards and i'm gonna
make sure that i can then refinance it
high enough i don't know what the exact
number is probably like 130
and then to be able to then pull out all
of my money
now sometimes you end up leaving a
little bit in but you should
definitely be aiming to pull out
everything
recycle your money most people are like
i've got a pot of money
where should i invest it or even worse
where should i spend it
no you should be recycling it
putting it in somewhere and then pulling
it out leaving you with
an asset with no money left in and then
what you're gonna do you're gonna do it
again
and again you're gonna and you're gonna
make your money work really hard for you
that's that's how the brr by
refurbishing finance
strategy should be done okay exotic
gaming hi samuel i've got 17 000
savings but i was thinking of getting
shared ownership so i've got my own
place to live but i want to become
financially free what would you
recommend uh i would recommend not doing
the shared ownership thing
because you want to be financially free
shared ownership has got so many flaws
if you buy a property on shared
ownership
it's very difficult to get out of it
because normally if you if you buy a
house and then you want to sell it you
just sell it
if you buy into a shared ownership
scheme and then you want to get out of
it we're gonna do you have to find
somebody else that wants to get into the
sucky scheme
you have to find another dum-dum and
then you have to pay
rent and mortgage
and you're probably going to end up
having to pay over the odds as well
like the the the ratio is
disproportioned
i'm not a fan i'm really not a fan so
do your research okay don't listen to me
go in with your eyes wide open do your
research okay
um manav pancholi
do you think there's demands for rent to
rents
in the east midlands absolutely
i got a whole bunch of students killing
it in east midlands
derby nottingham both with rent to hmos
and
rent to service to compartments
nottingham is
ripe for both of those strategies bang
one in the east midlands so 100 i do
matt rooney struggling to get a buy to
that mortgage at the minute
120 000 pound purchase with a 30 grand
gifted deposit
okay that shouldn't be a problem uh
35 grand a year tax after income no
outgoings other than residential
mortgage we started in december clean
and clear credit file
um you should be you should be okay
i mean december you got a residential
mortgage in december
sometimes it will help you if you've
owned a property for six months
so december january february march april
may you might find next month it
suddenly becomes a lot easier
but if you're having issues you just
need to speak to a mortgage advisor and
if you're having issues with your
current mortgage advisor
find another mortgage advisor because
you should you should be fine for what
you've said um
but it depends i don't know anything
about you you're just uh
matt rooney from youtube i love you
there bro okay
um sm thank you for your continued
support and property i remember you you
asked a question last week about
the difference between leasehold and
freehold and i said be careful of
leasehold
and now you've said my question is would
you purchase a leasehold property
you asked me that last week oh there's
more though as a bite select with a
remaining lease of 125 years oh um would
i
maybe assuming the numbers stack also
what happens when the term of the lease
comes to an end
would the value of the property not
decrease as the remaining
term of the lease is reduced over the
years yeah so if you buy
okay if there's 125 years on the on the
leasehold
and the numbers stack would i buy it
maybe yeah think of a stack i would
because 125 years is a long time
like we probably won't be around unless
they invent a magic pill which i don't
think they will
um so what will happen at the end of
when the lease runs out
is your children who you've inherited
the property to
will have to either sell the property
for really cheap
um or extend the lease
to be honest i've never had that happen
to me but i know what will happen you
have to extend the lease but you could
if you buy a property with a lease on it
for 125 years
in 50 years if you've got at least 75 or
in 75 years when you've only got 50
years left you could you can
you can pay to renew the lease but
it just costs money so it's just about
again it's about going in
with your eyes wide open so you know
exactly what's what
and a good solicitor should be able to
tell you exactly what you know exactly
what's what when you buy another sole
property
um in plain english here's a tip when
you're buying a property
make sure that you've got a good
solicitor and what i mean by good
solicitor is
usually someone that invests in property
themselves and someone that can speak
plain english so that you understand
what they're talking about that's
a good sign of a good solicitor all
right
saith's channel samuel i'm finding it
too hard to find
thirty percent below market value deals
for brr
you don't need thirty percent be it
below market value
what you need for a brr is you need to
be able to push up the value
i mean you can pay 100 of the market
value
when you're buying a brr potential deal
you need three figures you need to know
the purchase price it doesn't need to be
the market value
the refurb cost and the end
value the end value
needs to be a lot bigger than these two
figures
namely if you take the n value
and times it by 0.75
that number needs to be equal to or
greater than
the total investment namely the purchase
price
and the refurb cost maybe you need to
rewind and watch that back
but that's the formula nowhere in the
formula does it say that you need to buy
below market value you need to push the
value up
um all right last question ted says
i applied for the right to buy
my one bedroom flat from social housing
i've lived in it for 12 years
the discount on that bad boy is gonna be
big so
ted i'm glad to hear that but there's
more
and i applied for the right to buy some
years back
good i never completed the application
ah
you need to bro listen even the dude
sitting behind the camera
darwin you there bro when he came on as
my video before what happened i would
want to do the same thing yeah he had a
property he had the same thing
and literally i made you right i was
like
i was like you have the right to buy it
was like i do yeah but i've got a few
things going on in my mind and
you know i was like no no i don't care
what's going on in your mind
and literally i made him and now you've
got that going through
almost to complete boom what's the
discount on that
112 000 discount that's like 40 below
market value or something almost 50
so if you're there 12 years ted i'm
talking to you now ted
i hope ted i hope you can hear this i
hope you didn't just comment and then
disappear off you better
but guys please subscribe because i
don't want you to comment ask a question
and then and then don't hear the answer
so ted you never completed the
application
but now i have a family of four and have
been informed if i buy it i have to live
in it for five years
which is already difficult also it's on
the 10th floor with no outside space i
need a home for my family
please let me know where i should start
with no savings
i don't think you're correct ted i think
you've been
misinformed ted um look you don't
my understanding okay i've never
actually done mates
but i've looked into it heavily for many
of my students
my understanding is you don't have to
live in it for five years bro
you just can't sell it with
within five years and if well you can
sell it but you're not gonna
look let me explain if you're doing
right to buy right if you've lived in a
property for a long time and it's a
council owned property
if you've been there for a long time the
council will give you a discount to buy
it it's called right to buy
great if you've been for a long time
like ted i like my videographer
long time the discount can be huge
like that the apartment can be worth 300
grand and they'll say you can have it
for one sixth day
now you've got to get the money you
can't
walk away from a 50 below market value
deal
that only you on the planet have the
right to buy you just cannot walk away
from it
if you don't have the money find the
money if you can't find the money i
don't know
call me okay maybe we can do something
but
if you have the right to buy here's what
you can't do you can't say to the
council
hey i'll buy it for 160. buy it for 160
and then the next day stick it on right
move
for 300. set it for 300 and make a quick
150 grand boom shaka you can't do that
and if you do do that you have to you're
going to lose the discount you're going
to make 300 but you can then owe the
council money
now there's a sliding scale over a
five-year period
if you sell it after three years you
might make 150 grand profit
but you have to give the council some of
that money but
after five years you can sell
that bad boy take the
money right so you don't have to live in
it you just can't
sell it now my understanding is in
england
you unless they've just suddenly changed
the rules like i haven't heard but i
don't have
you can even rent it out is that right
am i right
cool so so so you can buy it for 160
when it's worth 300
argument's sake buy it really cheap
stick a tenant in it make an income
make an income then after five years
you probably won't be selling it for 300
it would have probably gone up now
because properties appreciate
it probably 400 that's how you're gonna
get rich so
you're telling me you've got no money if
you don't buy that property
i need to come around your house and
punch you in the mouth like
because there's no point even watching
my channel and being a subscriber if
you're going to have an opportunity that
lucrative that no one else
in the world has the opportunity to but
you have the right to buy it
and then just go oh but i don't know i'm
not sure like serious like
find a way to buy that house
let me know what happens my videographer
man did it you're gonna do it too
if you're a subscriber on my channel i
badly want you to be successful
i badly want you to become a property
tycoon and financially free i believe
that there's enough money
on the planet for everybody to live a
good life money is unlimited
people say what do you teach someone if
you make so much money in property
because
i don't feel like i'm in any competition
with anybody if anything we're going to
collab
we're going to collab you know so
if you want to get rich first thing you
need to do you want to get rich
very first thing you're going to do is
subscribe to the channel
hit like drop a question below thanks
for watching i look forward to seeing
you
next time